The leading generals of World War Two,
you carried a huge weight on their shoulders.
Their decisions could mean the difference between life and death for thousands
of men and their actions helped shape the fate of nations.
History has judged some of them as falls.
Others as butches and a handful of Basil military geniuses view that,
at least on the airline side,
have generated as much controversy in life and death.
As George S.
Patton,
the flamboyance American commander never lost a major battle,
but his explosive temper almost cost him his career.
He survived two world wars,
often placing himself in considerable danger in lead to die in unlikely
circumstances within months of Germany's defeat.
The unconventional general was a devout Christian,
and yet he believed he was just the latest incarnation of a warrior spirit who'd
once fought alongside the likes of Julius Caesar,
Napoleon Bonaparte,
and others.
He was the epitome of the rough,
tough warrior who reveled in his macho image and seemingly lived only for war,
but he could be a surprisingly sensitive individual who cried at funerals and
even pens,
poetry doing this for most of his life.
In this biographics video.
We're going to dive right into the details of this man's life.
[inaudible]
Georgia is passive.
Well,
he was born in California on the 11th 1885 20 years earlier.
The paths and family had lost a bunch of their wealth when they found themselves
on the losing side of American civil war.
However,
by the time of George's birth,
capacitors were prosperous and they were influential.
Once again,
the young George Welch,
he knew from an early age that he wanted to be a soldier is main obstacles to
doing this where his weaknesses in maths and English,
this wasn't a result of any lack of ability,
but rather his father's mistrust of form and education,
which meant that George had to descended school until he reached 12 years of
age.
He caught up quickly but only narrowly passed the entrance exam for West Point.
America's most prestigious military academy while pattern would regularly
clashed with his superiors during World War Two is conduct at West Point's was
exemplary.
He was particularly successful that sports such as Polo and football,
playing with some relentless aggression that he broke several bones.
He would lead to bring this aggression to his method of waging war
patterns,
considerable sporting ability.
It did not go on notice to do a selected to represent the United States of
America in the modern pentathlon at the 1912 Stockholm and then big games he
would could be,
is it writing,
shooting,
fencing,
running,
and sweating.
All things that pattern excels at.
Interestingly,
in the event it was patterns shooting that may let him down.
He fired 20 bullets,
but the judges ruled that three of them had missed the target pattern,
remained adamant that his aim but actually been too good and his shots and pass
through the whole he'd already made and the Bullseye.
It is possible that he was corrected,
but the judge is ultimately ruled against him.
At the end of the first day pattern was placed in a slightly disappointing 21st
from a 41 competitors.
Strong performances in each of the remaining events that saw him climb all the
way to fifth place.
It was the first and last time he competed in the Olympic Games,
but he didn't have to wait long to test the accuracy of his shooting in a combat
situation.
Yeah.
By 1916 most of the world's great powers were locked together in seemingly
interminable conduct.
Only the United States thus far succeeded in avoiding being drawn into the
slaughter.
However,
Lyrica did suffer a surprise attack from the direction of Mexico on Boston.
1916 400 heavily armed bandits led by notorious Francisco pantry video stormed
across the border for two hours.
They ran Saxons lucid the border town of Columbus before finally being chased
away by the cavalry.
If Divia believed he could hide out safely in Mexico,
well,
he was sorely mistaken.
President Woodrow Wilson ordered that the u s army crossed the border and put an
end to the threat.
John Pershing was given commands of the Expeditionary Force and he chose pattern
to serve as his eight Pason would go on to become famous for his skill.
That commanding fast moving motorized forces,
so it's perhaps fitting that one in Mexico.
He took part in the first motorized action in the history of warfare traveling
in three dodge touring cars pattern and his men launched a raid on videos
henchman.
When the smoke cleared at the end of a brief firefight,
three of his bodyguards lay debt pass an audit their bodies to be strapped to
the cars for the drive back to headquarters.
Pershing,
well,
he was apparently impressed reportedly saying this pattern boy,
he's a real fighter.
On the 6th of April,
1917 the United States of America declared war on Germany and entered World War
One.
Pershing was giving commands if the American expeditionary force and once again
he took George Patton at his side.
Pershing offered him an infantry battalion,
but by that time that passenger had become fascinated by tanks.
They were powerful,
yet unreliable weapons that were still in their infancy since they'd been
unleashed by the British at the song.
In September of 1916 he became the first officer assigned to the American
Expeditionary Force tank.
Core ams was at one of the first Americans to learn how to operate a tank and
it's personally towards the first cruise to be assigned to the tank corps.
The American Expeditionary Force tank core finally went into action in September
of 1918 with pattern riding battle or clinging to the outside of one of them
machines.
Please.
That same month though,
he would be badly injured in an act of near suicide or bravery,
world war one tanks that they were seriously underpowered.
They were unreliable and they were totally vulnerable without infantry support.
So when his tanks,
it became isolated.
During the Meuse Argonne offensive.
Patton calls for volunteers to help him storm the German lines.
Only five men have stepped forward.
They were quickly cut it down by a hail of German bullets patterned himself.
He was badly injured by a piece of shrapnel,
which hits him in the fight.
He continued to direct to the battle for Michelle.
Hobo anti later refused medical treatment until he had completed and submitted
his report.
Patton's injuries,
while they weren't life threatening,
they were serious.
So by the time he had recovered sufficiently to resend it to combat,
well,
the armistice had been signed and the guns said form and sign it
fall class and his time at the front lines haven't been brief.
He had done more than enough to demonstrate that he possessed the kinds of raw
courage he expected and demanded of those who served under him.
Okay.
With a great war or is it ends passing [inaudible] of the United States of
America where he founds a good deal to keep him busy.
He learns to fly drones.
The latest automobile sales is a yacht mixed with high society.
He kept a stable of horses and one hundreds of trophies and ribbons in numerous
sporting events,
such an extravagant lifestyle would ordinarily be well out of reach for him.
Majors,
salary.
However,
in 1910 patented married Beatrice [inaudible] of the extremely wealthy rs of a
Boston industrialist,
the battens.
Well,
they had enough money to do pretty much whatever they wanted,
but George never wavered from his belief that he was destined to be a great
soldier.
He maintained a special interest in armored warfare and some visionaries.
We're proclaiming the tanks would become the decisive weapon in any future
conflicts.
Hines Gadarian in Germany and Charles de Gaulle in France,
I'll give the tanks,
would return mobility to the battlefields punching through enemy positions to
create havoc in the rear passenger.
He was thinking along similar lines and he got the chance to test out some of
his ideas.
In 1941 when the U s army held fast war games across the states of Louisiana and
Carolina,
more than 400,000 soldiers and 1000 Aircrafts took part in mock battles,
held over 30,000 square miles with Germany.
Once again at war with Britain and Russia.
Ben's no guarantees that America would be able to remain neutral.
It was a much needed opportunities.
You get to test out tactics and equipments.
It also served as a test of the men who would lead America's armies into battle.
The battles they weren't real,
but they were a police,
enough approximation for 61 men to lose their lives.
However,
despite these losses,
the U s army gained valuable experience and pattern staked his claim.
Do you arguably be the US army's finest exponents of Ahmed [inaudible].
Oh,
okay.
On the 7th of December,
1941 Japan attacked to the United States of America.
That's pal harbor.
Four days later,
Germany declared war on America.
As with that World War Two became they truly global war with plans for a 1942
allies,
invasion of western Europe having been shelved.
The high command instead chose to strike it.
Hitler's vishing French allies in North Africa.
Three separate task forces were launched with General George Patton at taking
command of 35,000 men of the Western task force ceiling at the Casablanca from
Virginia.
It pass on that has any fears or doubts?
Well,
he certainly wasn't a showing them as he wrote in his diary.
When I realize what I am,
I am amazed,
but on reflection,
who is as good as I am,
I know of no one I've ever had.
Lee.
He was fairly modest to the amphibious landings of the 8th of November when
largely unopposed and despite some fierce resistance as patterns men pushed
inlands.
The Vichy French signed an armistice later that day,
far more formidable than the French.
However,
with Germany is a win.
Rommel and his Africa court on the 14th of February,
1943 they attacked in force striking a u s troops in years Atlas Mountains.
By the 20th of February,
the immediate crisis it was over,
but the Americans,
they'd been pushed back 50 miles.
Huge amounts of equipment had been abandoned and 4,000 Americans including
pattern zones.
Son in law had been captured by the Germans with morale on the floor and those
and how a sac to the commander,
he held responsible and placed all American troops in Tunisia under patterns,
commands person immediately subjected as men to an intensive drill routine and
strict disciplinary coat.
His methods weren't far from university popular,
but they got results and within a month pattern was on the offensive defeating
the formidable German 10th Panzer Division at the Battle of El Guitar passing
rapidly build himself a reputation in north Africa,
but it was here at the t began his rivalry with Bernard Montgomery,
the commander of the British Eighth Army while passing.
It was bold,
aggressive,
and often acted on gut instinct.
Montgomery.
It was by nature,
read far more cautious man.
You put great stock in meticulous planning,
patterned believed Eisenhower deferred to Montgomery,
far too often a feeling that was only strengthens when the British commander was
given the go ahead to plan the invasion of Sicily.
Okay.
The invasion of Sicily was to be a joint operation conducted the British Eighth
Army led by Montgomery as the u s seventh on the commanded blink George Pattern,
much to persons discussed the Montgomery's plan place.
The main emphasis on the British contingent and cast the Americans in the
supporting role.
This is what you get fumed pattern when your commander in chief Eisenhower
ceases to be an American hands becomes an ally.
The invasion force,
it landed on the beaches of Sicily on the 10th of July,
1943 by nice for the allies had put 80,000 men and 300 tanks or short.
The next day it patterned himself came to inspect the beachhead,
wading in the through the surf,
even as artillery shells exploded around the beach.
While it seemed became clear that the Germans would not be able to hold Sicily.
They fought a fierce rear guard action as they began to evacuated their army to
the Italian mainland's.
As Montgomery's army became bogged down at pattern,
decided to take a loose interpretation of his orders.
He was expected to support the British,
but I mean surely the best way to do this would be to hit the Germans heart
pattern.
Dhruv the seventh army on his goal now was to beat him Montgomery to the city of
[inaudible] in the north of the islands.
He was driven not just by his personal ambition,
but by a desire to prove that the American soldier was the best in the world.
The Sicily campaign was fought at a blistering pace in blazing heat casualties.
Well,
they were inevitable on August,
1943 paths and visited the wounded at a field hospital.
When he discovered that one of the patients was physically unhurt but suffering
from shell shock,
he exploded with rage pattern.
It slaps to the unfortunate man dragged in from the tent and kicked him in the
backside and then threatened to shoot him for cowardice.
Unfortunately,
for pattern,
this extraordinary display had been conducted under the noses of a number of
journalists patterned and it seemed to realize had done anything wrong,
but striking.
A subordinate was a court martial offense.
Eisenhower ordered pattern to apologize bags of the witnesses not to report on
the incidents and hoped that that would be enough to protect his most dangerous
weapon in the war against the Nazis spa pattern one is rest in Messina and
through the Nazis out of Sicily is vicious.
Temper came back to bite him as word.
If his assaults leaked out in the press,
there was this or more Eisenhower could do pattern.
He was removed from his commands and with that it seemed as if his Korea,
it might be over
the invasion of Italy,
was a natural result of the conquest of Sicily.
Patton,
who was ill suited to inactivity B could only watch on in frustration of even
greater importance than the campaign and this,
and he was the long awaited invasion of western Europe.
This would take place in June of 1944 it was one of the most difficult
operations of the war.
There's pattern would have it,
no direct role to play in the invasion.
Instead though there was used as a decoy given commands of an entirely
fictitious army intended to fool the Germans into believing that a second
invasion force was preparing to strike the ruse.
It totally worked.
The Germans never imagines that the allies would leave their best offensive
general back in Britain.
While such a vote of the offensive was being fought in France.
Okay,
awesome.
Greatest fear was that the war would be before he could get back into it.
He needs tons of worried though.
While the success of the initial allied invasion exceeded expectations,
the British and the Americans made slow progress as they attempted to push
inland's.
It wasn't until the end of July for the Americans finally punched the small hole
through the German lines.
Omar Bradley,
commander of the U s grounds forces knew that this was the moment to get pattern
back into the frame.
Radley it regarded pattern as difficult to control and predictable and vulgar,
but he recognized his talents pattern was given commands of the newly formed
Third Army,
a Heidi mobile force equipped with plenty of art that he was ordered to go back
and it's break through the German lines pattern that quickly got to work,
squeezed his armored divisions through the narrowest of gaps in the German
lines,
reform them on the other side and within a matter of days is Third Army was
tearing through open country and to Brittany.
The speed of patterns.
Advances often worry to superior.
Since he was a risk taker,
he rarely worried about the danger of an attack to his flanks.
Hitler himself actually thought it sniffed out and opportunity to exploit the
allied breakout.
He would launch a counterattack and cutoff patterns Ahmed's spearheads.
Now this idea,
well,
it did have its merits in theory,
but the German army lacked the strength.
Do you execute the operation in practice?
It was instead the Germans,
he found themselves in danger of being complete and the encircled at filets pass
and believed he was in a position to slam the drawers of the trap shot.
Bradley a far more cautious,
commanded them Patton or did the Third Army to halt our Jensen passing.
He was furious,
but he complied with the order even though he suspected Bradley had been
influenced by Montgomery.
Yeah,
headless fails.
Counselor attack LEDs to the near collapse of the German army in France without
a pattern.
It was freeze and launches blitzkrieg assaults.
His philosophy was relentless attack and unrelenting pressure that caps the
enemy constantly off balance and to minimize the Third Army casualties pattern
argued that if he was properly back,
so you've got to cross the river Rhine and a matter of weeks spots pass and
found himself at once again in competition with Montgomery,
as each man is empty,
do you secure enough supplies to keep their army moving as passing complains,
my man can eat their belts,
spares.
My tanks have got to have gas.
Although there were such disagreements amongst the leading ally generals,
they were United in the belief that Hitler's armies were all but beaten.
Germany's Phurah.
However,
had one last surprise in store on the 16th of December,
1944 the Germans launched a vast counter attack aimed at a thinly held section
of the American lines at our den.
This was the beginning of the battle that we had become famous as the battle of
the bulge,
the at southern and furious.
The soul's badly rattles,
most allied commodities that's and recognized once that Hitler had made a
serious strategic error.
Let the sons of bitches go all the way to Paris.
If they like your job's,
then we can really cut them off and shoot them up.
Eisenhower to senior commanders do an emergency conference where he asked how
long it would take a pattern.
Do you divert his third army to the Adana pattern?
Told him he could have three divisions there within 48 hours.
This seemingly fantastical claim was matched with a mixture of laughter.
Then disbelieving stairs,
but pattern.
He was in tiny,
serious hit anticipated Eisenhower's request and just staff were already making
preparations.
Do you disengage the part of the third army in order to wheel it around,
they would then race to the rescue along narrow icy roads.
The Battle of the bulge gave of the allied high commands,
a shock lets as pattern had predicted is accomplished nothing and cost.
Hitler has lost reserves now.
The River Rhine was the last significant obstacles that the western allies have
to tackle.
The main crossing was to be launched Irvine,
Montgomery.
Mattie spent two months planning every last detail of the operation,
which calls for an airborne assault,
a huge artillery bombardments and even the assistance of specialized the US navy
vessels.
Well Gum Murray's crossing was launched on the 23rd of March by which time
pattern had already stolen his thumbs up,
like quietly sneaking a division across under the cover of darkness and
establishing a bridgehead on the other side.
He phones Bradley to let him know what he'd done but don't tell anyone.
He said because the crowds haven't realized yet
with its feeds of Germany and tried and failed to secure a posting to the Far
East in order to play a part in the war against Japan.
Instead,
he was appointed as governor of the Varian,
the political posts.
Twitchy was not well suited.
He fell out with the Russians,
refused to remove Nazi personnel from key administrative positions on the basis
that there was nobody else qualified to do the job,
and it's got to tricks by a reporter into agreeing that Nazis joins the party
and more or less the same way as Americans became Democrats or Republicans
patterns,
political abilities didn't really compare to his military abilities.
Angie,
once again succeeded in outraging the press.
His subsequent apology was deemed insufficient.
Tends.
He was removed from his post for the second time,
but at this point,
although he didn't know it,
he had only a few months left to live on December the ninth 1945 pattern was
being driven towards a hunting expedition when the vehicle he was traveling in
was struck by a truck traveling in the opposite direction.
Nobody else was hurt.
That's passing,
was paralyzed from the neck down the injured general.
He was rushed to hospital where he died 11 days later,
he was buried in Europe alongside the fallen soldiers who was beloved Third Army
Patton.
It always wanted to die in battle,
but instead he lost his life as the result of a low speed collision in
peacetime.
Now,
most everybody accepts the official version of patterns demise and it has been
suggested the person may have been assassinated by the Russians,
possibly even in collusion with the u s government.
This would have been as a result of his outspoken opposition to the Soviet Union
when he died,
he was 60 years old,
so I really hope you enjoyed that video.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below and don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos twice a week.
Also,
if you like this video,
check out some of our other videos which were linking to over there on the right
and as always,
thank you for watching.